vaccinations resuming at both cashman
or andover at the convention center for
those that are 16 and older many telling
a news now
they had been waiting for this day for a
long time thank you for joining us at
six o'clock i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise valdez sally jaramillo is live
tonight just outside the convention
center with how the lines were at both
of those locations
sally brian and denise as you can see
behind me there are no more cars left
but earlier this morning this entire
parking lot
was full and many families telling me
they are super excited that they can
finally come together
and get vaccinated now take a look at
this video we shot this morning
outside cashman center travis haldeman a
fire engineer for clark county who
manages the site says they have been
preparing for weeks
there were lines at catchment center but
they moved quickly the wait time
about 30 minutes recently they were
administering more than 6 000 vaccines a
day
they plan to do more moving forward
justin flashner came with his dad and
brother matthew to get vaccinated
i'd say most people my age should get it
because
most people my age want to get back out
and like be able to get back to somewhat
similar life that we had before and with
the vaccine
you'll definitely be able to do that i
finally was able to get a
my driver's license so i want to start
you know going out doing more things
that's what it is to be
you know a teenager well
everyone 16 and over is now eligible
there are many still concerned about
getting it the health district plans to
continue outreach to change people's
minds
now for more information on where you
can get the vaccine visit our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting live sally
jaramillo 8 news now
sally thanks for that report and if you